من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي
لافروف ان الولايات المتحده منعت كافه
الجهود والمبادرات الهادفه الى وقف اراقه
الدماء في فلسطين واضاف ان الموقف
الامريكي المتارجح بين استخدام الفيتو
والدعوه الى خفض حده الاعمال العدائيه هو
بمثابه تفويض مطلق للعقاب الجماعي المستمر
بحق
الفلسطينيين لم يتمكن المجلس حتى الان من
تقديم الرد المناسب على هذا التحدي المصير
حقه ونحن نعرف السبب وهو الموقف الامريكي
لقد منعت الولايات المتحده كافه الجهود
والمبادرات الهادفه الى وقف راقه الدماء
في الاراضي المحتله الامر الصادم هو مادام
مراوغه الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه فهي تتارجح
بين استخدام حق النقض ضد القرارات
المتعلقه بوقف القتال وفي نفس الوقت
الدعوه الى خفض حده الاعمال العدائيه في
غزه ولا شك ان هذا مثابه تفويض مطلق
للعقاب الجماعي المستمر بحق
الفلسطينيين